I've been picked up since in jeff's can
handle and I think it's partially
because these topics are not now trendy
in the West but it's also strange to me
that now it's an open topic and it
doesn't doesn't work yet in Poland and
then above all and here I find many of
you may have seen the book by timothy
snyder what i find the greatest failing
of that book but a much of Polish
historiography this is not polish the
story of it as well is the desire to
view Ukrainians only within the
Commonwealth and to forget that after
cool its keys great revolt a lot the
sizable body of Ukrainian territory and
population is outside of the
Commonwealth and they form the culture
of the hetman eight of these of the
seventeenth and eighteenth century and
therefore the modern ukrainian national
national formation of the 19th century
comes to a considerable degree not from
territories that were in the
commonwealth but from territories that
were outside the commonwealth it is that
left bank area of ukraine that is the
center of the ukrainian national
movement at the beginning of the 19th
century and the therefore the desire to
reduce ukrainian the cranium question to
just the commonwealth distorts that
historiography and so i would call it
the blind around the hetman ache now
what about Ukraine first of all I talked
about the good historians who worked in
Ukraine in the period difficult period
there were as well a sizeable number of
parable historians who still worked on
that period and they then work on and
they produce students and I think that
there are great failing still of
Ukrainian historiography from all the
years that it could not carry on normal
study source study people didn't learn
Latin well how are they going to work on
this period if they didn't know Latin
and other such problems so it is limited
and then of course Ukraine is
economically collapsing so not only is
is there the general problem of modern
period but how many people are going to
go into history I also think there is
the remnant of hyper patriotism it was
natural in the early 1990s after the
Soviets had not allowed you to be
patriotic to be very patriotic and in
the old days one of the few ways you
could be patriotic was against the
Polish nobility you couldn't write
against the
Russian rule you can write but you could
run but you could write against the
Polish nobility that continues on to a
considerable degree in this in Ukrainian
historiography of this day there are on
the other hand very positive signs
regrettably there are no chairs of
Polish history in Ukraine so the Polish
history doesn't exist outside of
relations with Ukraine which I find is
limits the field but within that field
there are contributions being made we
mentioned the power yoga Vanka a
historian who has been extremely
influential creative open to polish
historiography and I think has done much
to bring the achievements of Polish
historiography too much of Ukrainian
historiography and is definitely someone
who might be called even an anti
nationalist indeed there would be her
those who would call her a cool ashika
this another panteleimon coolish type
person of our generation there are those
who criticize her strongly for these
reasons including professors as I
average and others who see her as too
much a copying polish models without
thinking about them in new ways and not
contributing to them and there are many
others who criticize her as well but it
begins a political it interesting
historic graphic debate in Ukraine
occurs over yup event CO and her work
and her histories and that I think will
advance the field in many ways now what
I've tried to do is show what the state
of historical play is at the moment I
think the reason it is particularly
important that this these discussions
continue in a new way is one as I've
said I think that the rethinking of the
polish-lithuanian Commonwealth in Poland
that one would have expected to have
happened with the opening of of archives
and material in the East is not going on
as quickly as it might and I brought out
this issue of the Ukrainian national
formation in the hetman eight as one
case where we can see that if more poles
read Ukrainian and read Ukrainian
historiography they might begin to think
even about the Commonwealth in new ways
by studying Terran thinking of
territories outside it and on the other
hand this Ukrainian historiography
that's
developing which as I say is improving
but needs needs quite a bit of time